do you find that turn-based combat uh
almost benefits when it's simpler as
opposed to being very complicated
I think there's a fine balance whereas
like I've played like a variety of like
super simple turn bass to like [__]
simple like Pokemon yeah Pokemon is very
simple right it's you you choose between
four moves at most you know
um some item management and that's about
it in party management right yeah
whereas you play you know like some
early Final Fantasy games for example
where it's like all like you know some
of the Dragon Quest games where you just
have like every character has like 70
different spells 70 different items you
can choose from I think It suffers quite
a lot when it's over complicated because
you just like you look online you're
like here's the most broken combo that
you can do that one shots enemies yeah
because the devs didn't think about
combining [__] stupid spells yeah
like this yeah it's like because how
could you have yeah and the game's only
comp Patrick yeah so yeah maybe there's
just when it's too complicated I always
find this either you're always over
you're either completely over optimized
and you're one-shotting everything yeah
later on in the game or you're
completely under optimized because you
do you're playing the game normally and
you're like I don't [__] know how
this all interacted yeah yeah like I
think there is a like a balance there's
there's like a golden spot where there
is some complexity to it but there's not
too much that you kind of get overloaded
because uh that's pretty straightforward
right yeah Persona personas you do
physical attack you shoot a weapon or
you use spells that's yeah for me like
Persona has that perfect balance some
some more traditional jrpgs like
um like I'm gonna go back to Trails for
example which you know on top of its
combat system it has like the equipment
system as well and it's there are so
many different [__] ways you can
build a character which is like great to
some people but I'm just like uh I just
like because here's the thing for it
like in intros like it goes through like
stages so you have like you have like a
certain storyline then you go to the
next story line the next story line
um and I was like looking up guides and
apparently there's like Optimal builds
you can do for each character that suits
that like Mission the most and I'm like
and I'm like this is too much prep time
for me to play the game I just want to
play the game I want to get through the
story but sometimes I spend like [__]
hours just going to the shop being like
okay what are the new items available
now what are the new um courts available
now okay how do I how do I optimize
these for my party which is like already
out of like eight members in my party so
you need to choose four members from
your eight member party and then out of
those four members you have to decide
what equipment you want to give give
them how you want to build them and
that's just for one Mission I
extrapolate that for like eight missions
in in term in terms of the entire game
I'm like this is this is too much that
was my exact problem with the new Fire
Emblem game as well right where it's
like where I was like that was the one
game where I realized I was like oh
maybe having too many playable
characters is actually detrimental to
the game because the new fire alarm game
you can literally play like 40 different
characters yeah it's like and there's
like Guides Online of like all right so
uh with this character you can do this
optimal build and this character you can
do this optimal unless you're gonna be
doing this Mission with these characters
and I'm just like I just want all the
cute girls in my team again just make
them all op and just [__] power
through it in somebody's call my game
with like four characters that feel fun
to play and all feel very distinct and
unique and have good like personality
and character writing is so much more
compelling than 50 flashy characters
that I can customize in a million
different ways I was like just just just
[__] give me something good yeah
don't throw a bunch of [__] at me that
looks pretty exactly and I'm like I know
some people really love that aspect they
love like getting the spreadsheet out
and trying to optimize the build I I'm
not that gamer I once like for me I'm a
story kind of gamer I just want to get
through the story and just you know I
want to feel a little bit rewarded for
doing some cool [__] in the gameplay but
I don't want to work that hard where I'm
where I'm literally like spending hours
upon hours trying to like read through
stats read yeah yeah I remember in the
Fire Emblem one I was like all right I'm
gonna see like just what the internet
has to say about like which characters
might be best some [__] had
created a [__] tier list of like
literal tier list of the characters from
like s to f right and I was like all
right let's see where my choice the
characters are the majority of them were
like D or F and I'm just like well you
know what [__] this list I like these
characters I like so I'm gonna [__]
use them yeah I don't care like all the
top tier characters are like all the
boring characters and I'm like okay
what's more important me like having an
easy time and like optimizing my
gameplay to make it so that I just Crush
everything or make it a little bit more
challenging but just have the joy of
playing the characters I actually want
to play as yeah right yeah I'll always
take the latter in that instance yeah
and to me like a lot of that that's a
lot of reason why I don't like
turn-based combat it's because not only
the time-based combat itself but the
prep that comes before the turn base
combat uh and I think the two games I've
played where I've liked the turn-based
combat is when they've hit that
Goldilocks zone where uh it's uh just
you have you can you can prep you can
think about your team com but it doesn't
take too much time and it's still
rewarding and the two ones are now
Persona and now Hong Kai because those
have like hit the Pokemon
I tried getting Pokemon but it's just
too easy I don't know it's just I mean
that's why people make artificial
difficulty yeah you make challenges out
of it and stuff because it you know adds
a whole other layer to it I think
nuzlocks are also in that golden look
yeah those looks great of like just it's
like it's challenging enough where you
need to do some prep work and you need
to think about like team structure but
it doesn't take so much time that it
takes the fun out of it right you know
and and you know it's like it's super
rewarding when you win it's super
punishing when you lose but it just
makes you want to keep coming back right
like you've been doing a lot of nuzlocks
recently yeah dude fun people like it
it's easy to understand yeah it's like
dark souls for kids
Dark Souls baby steps man I like how a
dark souls and synonyms for just
difficulty yeah I mean Dark Souls are
turned to difficulty actually uh
difficulty in video games didn't exist
Before Dark Souls definitely not that's
also [__] yeah sorry don't just go back
to it again but that's one thing I also
really liked about um the 300 game is
that like uh like every everything
because because all the fights were
unnecessary it was really interesting
because like you had a talk option with
whoever you were fighting right it's
always risky to do it because what if
you talk to them they'd [__] clap you
and then you're like [__] I lost a turn
uh but then like Sunday some ways like
the only way to get characters to join a
party was mid-fight to talk to them and
this is never explained or anything like
that and it's really interesting course
because it was basically like how I
described it to people and how people
scrub to me was uh undertale meets
berserk
which is why I like that because it was
like fighting is cool and it's
turn-based combat but fighting isn't the
only option there's a lot of other ways
we've got approaching yeah you actually
got to find something
you can't figure out in berserk that's
yeah let's see how well that goes it's
like an undertale but if everyone wasn't
reasonable because it's realistic right
because somebody's thinking monsters
they don't [__] want to talk to you
yeah yeah of course the [__]
disembodied monster with his dick out
awesome on a tour are you kidding me no
it doesn't want to talk it wants to kill
you yeah why don't you try and talk to
you idiot yeah and it punishes you for
that so I like that that felt real uh I
think I just need games with Stakes I
guess the problem is that uh turn based
combat like a lot of RPGs or Japanese
give you a lot of saves they're like
very very generous with saves yeah yeah
and that almost kind of takes away from
my enjoyment because I'm like I just
don't feel like I have any difficulties
just too much of a game of
um the complete opposite I need to be
spoon-fed what the [__] like like I I do
not want to work for anything no no I I
like the idea of nuzlocks but like
unless the game was designed that way
I'm like why would I bring artificial
difficulties so much better than the
base game it's it's way more fun because
it's actually like his Pokemon
especially like new Pokemon yeah it's
like Google gaga [__] like that yeah
yeah everyone we're also adults now yeah
I know I know but like like those games
that are made for life okay but here's
here's what I can never do something
like a Nuzlocke okay when when you when
I'm playing I don't care about my
Pokemon I do I'm listening okay when
okay I I don't know if this is a mental
thing but like when I'm beating a game
that is designed to be difficult it's
it's like this is the way that it is
designed and I'm beating someone else's
work that is their work yeah when I'm
doing a Nuzlocke I am putting difficulty
upon myself so yeah basically the only
the only challenge the the only opponent
I'm trying to beat here is myself
because I'm imposing all the difficulty
on myself and I'm like I don't want to
do that I wanna I understand that yeah
yeah I I I I I don't want to challenge
myself I want to challenge someone else
I want to challenge someone else's
design if that makes sense no no that
totally makes sense and I'm normally in
the same boat with you yeah uh I think
there are just some exceptions where
it feels like there's a challenge that
is just lacking there and that
artificially making one does kind of
solve a lot of the issues perhaps the
game might have for somebody who I mean
I you know I'm not a kid it's the
Pokemon was not designed for me yeah oh
suddenly you had this kind of factor and
it becomes a lot more oh this is way
more engaging suddenly because now I'm
not just gonna go willy-nilly into every
fight I'm gonna have to actually think
and we have to plan just like randomized
nuzlocks are very fun because you just
like imagine gotcha then you don't know
where anything is and you're just like
all right this this character just one
shot at me and I have repercussions for
that uh I think that's the problem I
have with a lot of games is that they
just often don't punish you ever but
then punishing is a difficult thing to
do right like how do you add punishment
to a game or Stakes to a game that don't
actually uh just take advantage of your
time as a player yeah yeah like and so I
understand why a lot of games are like
let's just let's just make a good game
let's not let's not do that because also
not everyone wants that and I understand
that and I'm not imposing that on anyone
I'm not being like you have to play it
this way like there's a lot of games out
there especially like story driven games
where it's like this is not made so that
you struggle like this is great so you
can get to story beat to story beat
maybe there's a there's a hard boss here
and there but the most of it is pretty
doable yeah yeah and I understand that
um but that's why a lot of those games I
just don't I also don't go for because
that just doesn't appeal to me yeah it's
like an interactive movie well yeah like
there's a lot of games I've played
around like this is just uh the
cutscenes and then the gameplay is a
vehicle to the next Cuts yeah yeah uh I
haven't played like the last of us but I
imagine it's something similar it's the
gameplay is not that incredibly
difficult and it's more so about getting
from A to B yeah I mean that is 100 a
story right I mean I mean lots of us is
a HBO series in a video game that they
turned into a HBO series right like that
I would never be like you should do a
[__] no hit run of last year it's
like
why yeah yeah it's like you're trying to
snort a milkshake it's like it should
not yeah it's not made for that at all I
was actually like it's it's so weird now
because uh I I did actually watch The
Last of Us let's get just [__]
incredible insane right absolutely
incredible but now like after I've
watched the HBO Last of Us I can never
go back to playing the game because to
me it's just so much better I right yeah
I I I've I never I never played the game
right but I watched the TV show and I
was like man they've
given such a good depth to these
characters I just can't yeah imagine how
it would work in the game anymore I'm
sure it does but in my head I'm like I
just don't know how Okay because uh
someone who like I I was very
apprehensive about watching the like The
Last of Us HBO series because I'm just
like I've played the game I know the
story what else is there to do and I
kind of realize now the difference when
it comes to presenting a story in a
video game versus just watching a movie
or watching a TV series uh because the
story in The Last of Us HBO TV series
was just like perfectly paced yeah you
know it's it's just perfectly placed and
then now now what I what now when I go
back to playing the game I cannot just
think okay I'm getting the story in
little increments yeah right because I
need to I need to splice in the gameplay
between those little increments and you
know last of us is a very it's a [__]
great game but it's not got the greatest
gameplay in the world compared to other
you know other games in this genre of
what the thing that made it stand out
was the writing was so good and the
gameplay was good it enough to be like
okay this is good enough
um it's not gonna revolutionize the
industry with this gameplay but it's
good enough to uh get you through the
game and get you through the story and
now that the TV series exists I'm like
[__] now that a TV series exists I feel
like it's just completely made uh
like
it's completely made what's The Last of
Us game made that so special and just
like mute now because I'm just like if
you want to experience the story of The
Last of Us I feel like you should just
watch the TV series because that's
that's a better paced story that's told
not it's not told better but the the way
it's told the way is presented just
because of the nature of video games
versus movies it's just a better story
you know my favorite episode is like
episode three holy [__] which wasn't
even in the TV I loved that yeah such a
good episode and such a good way of
showing like characterization and yeah
how this zombie apocalypse would affect
certain people and yeah so that was
great uh I need to get on it it's so
it's so good
um yeah that's my favorite episode but
like the one thing that I thought the
show did really well which obviously
this is a lot easier to convey and I
felt like when I was when I was watching
it I was like how would you how would
you convey this in the game which was
they they make violence like violence
against other humans seem like a pretty
traumatic thing yeah for the young like
Ali the younger character to experience
yeah which in the game I feel like when
it's like all right go you control the
character gun down 50 men it just
doesn't feel like it doesn't feel
impactful but like watching maybe an
actor do that and the ramifications of
that it definitely feels like oh your
violence is bad
like but in video games you don't feel
like violence is bad cause you do it all
the [__] time
maybe I haven't played the game so I
don't know but the one thing that that's
the one thing I was like I wonder if
this is why
it was so divisive you know because
obviously I don't even know what
happened I don't know what happened
second game but I know the big plot
twist because everyone [__] it turns
like a woke right versus left thing yeah
yeah yeah and I wonder if that's almost
why
like the the second game which received
kind of badly was because maybe the game
didn't characterize Joel in a way that
made it seem question I don't know it's
kind of spoilers but I don't know like
sport kind of questionable maybe killing
people all the time I don't know yeah I
mean I think the second game took a very
very big risk yeah and I actually
respect them for taking that risk uh
because I didn't know how they were
gonna make a sequel to Last of Us
um and uh they they took a risk with
their story not it didn't gel with
everyone but that's that to me is the
sign of you know someone who wants to
like push you know push push the limit
and push the limit uh push the
storytelling uh I could see HBO doing it
right yeah I could just see him doing it
right they're like the kings of doing
controversial [__] and like look at
every goddamn Game of Thrones yeah yeah
yeah like they took the last of us which
is already a great story and great
characters and I think they made it
better and that that is that is what I
would that was that is what I took out
from being apprehensive about watching
The Last of Us originally
um I and now I'm just like if you want
to experience the loss of us I'd say
just watch the TV series because it's so
[__] good it's amazing yeah really
[__] good yeah super hyped for the
next season in like 10 years yeah that's
why I [__] get there it's gonna be so
long